there is no other way to put it roe vs
wade and its progeny are dead women in
the united states no longer have a
constitutional guaranteed right to an
abortion this video explains the how and
the why of everything that happened and
to do that we have to start with the
history of how we got roe vs wade in the
first place what is the source of a
constitutional right to an abortion in
the united states it is one of the
rights which fall under a general right
to privacy which is the right of people
to make personal decisions regarding
intimate matters now when you're talking
about the right to privacy you're
talking about unenumerated rights in the
constitution when the founders were
drafting the constitution they did not
set out to list all the rights which
americans could conceivably claim they
were well aware that by naming some of
the rights but not others future
governments might deny the people rights
that the founders believed were
important and this is why the
federalists originally did not want a
bill of rights to be included in the
constitution itself and as a compromise
rather than make a long list of rights
the founders included the ninth
amendment which states quote the
enumeration in the constitution of
certain rights shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others retained by the
people james madison in particular
reportedly said that the government
should never use the bill of rights as
an excuse to increase its powers over
areas of life that were not enumerated
in the constitution now the supreme
court really began fleshing out
unenumerated rights in the mid 20th
century particularly in a case called
griswold vs connecticut which voided a
statute that made it illegal for married
people to buy contraception the court
wrote that privacy was one of the values
implied by the first amendment which
protects the right of association
between people by the fourth amendment
which allows people to be secure in
their persons from government intrusions
and through the 14th amendment's
guarantee of due process
now in that case after reviewing a line
of cases in which the supreme court
identified rights not explicitly
enumerated in the constitution justice
douglas argued that the court could
infer a right to privacy by looking at
zones of privacy protected by other
parts of the constitution in overlapping
protections quote various guarantees
create zones of privacy the right of
association contained in the penumbra of
the first amendment is one as we have
seen the third amendment in its
prohibition against quartering of
soldiers in any house
in time of peace without the consent of
the owner is another facet of that
privacy the fourth amendment explicitly
affirms the right of the people to be
secure in their persons houses papers
and effects against unreasonable
searches and seizures the fifth
amendment in its self-incrimination
clause enables the citizen to create a
zone of privacy which government may not
force him to surrender to his detriment
the ninth amendment provides the
enumeration in the constitution of
certain rights shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others retained by the
people now griswold upheld the right of
married couples to decide private issues
of contraception and seven years later
eisenstadt vs baird extended griswold's
holding to unmarried people using some
of the same logic and following griswold
the court upheld a right to privacy and
struck down a number of laws including
those prohibiting interracial marriage
the constitution does not explicitly say
anything about marriage and in the mid
19th century the law offered interracial
couples no protection even from
prosecution in loving vs virginia the
court held that a virginia law
criminalizing interracial marriage
violated the due process clause of the
14th amendment chief justice earl warren
wrote under our constitution the freedom
to marry or not marry a person of
another race resides with the individual
and cannot be infringed by the state and
continuing with that logic the court
also relied on the 14th amendment to
process laws to strike down laws banning
prisoners from getting married while in
prison and in continuing in those line
of cases in 1973 roe vs wade established
a constitutional right to an abortion
through the fifth amendment among others
then the fifth amendment says no person
shall be deprived of life liberty or
property without due process of law now
courts have interpreted two types of due
process one is procedural due process
which are the rules that the government
must follow such as giving a person
notice a hearing and a fair tribunal and
then there's what's called substantive
due process which is the idea that
allows courts to establish and protect
certain fundamental rights from
government interference even if
procedural protections are present or
the rights are unenumerated now the roe
opinion begins with the long review of
the medical history of abortion it
reviews the history of abortion laws
finding that many prohibitions on
abortion were relatively modern the
court reviewed many religious and
philosophical traditions which contain
many different views about when or if
the unborn could be considered people
during different stages of pregnancy and
the court ruled that the word person as
used in the constitution did not include
the unborn the court concluded that the
14th amendment's concept of personal
liberty includes a right of personal
privacy over certain areas which include
whether a woman terminates a pregnancy
or not and the court also recognized
that the government could not make a
choice about whether the person
continues a pregnancy and the court held
that the state had valid interests that
justified regulation of pregnancy and
that the state's interest increased as
the pregnancy progressed then almost 20
years later the supreme court decided
another abortion case that substantially
revised roe that's planned parenthood
versus casey that case tested whether
states had the right to restrict
abortion including during the first
trimester the pennsylvania regulations
included a mandatory waiting period
spousal notification and parental
consent in the casey decision the
supreme court overturned roe's trimester
rule in favor of a viability analysis
and lowered the standard of review for
abortion restrictions from strict
scrutiny to an undue burden test and
under casey's undue burden test abortion
restrictions were unconstitutional if
they had the purpose or effect of
placing a substantial obstacle in the
path of a woman seeking an abortion of a
non-viable fetus the court held that
states could require parental consent
for a minor's abortion require waiting
period between seeking and obtaining an
abortion and require detailed informed
consent including medical information
about the abortion but the state
couldn't require a woman to sign a form
stating that she had given notice to her
husband that she was having an abortion
and again following in these cases in
2003 the supreme court cited loving
griswold eisenstadt casey and roe in
striking down a texas law that
criminalized sexual intimacy by same-sex
couples but not identical conduct by
straight couples the court held that the
law violated the 14th amendment's due
process clause as adults are free to
engage in private conduct in the
exercise of their liberty under the due
process clause quote
their right to liberty under the due
process clause gives them the full right
to engage in their conduct without
intervention of the government and
notably justice scalia dissented in this
case stating that the logic of the
decision would of course permit same-sex
marriage and in 2012 following in that
case the court proved him right by
legalizing same-sex marriage citing the
same string of cases that established
the right to choose one's intimate
relationships and whether to have
children
and when the court decided that case
obergefell versus hodges it observed
that if a person has the right to choose
whether to have an abortion then they
have the right to marry the person of
their choice now in the aftermath of
planned parenthood versus casey states
enacted more and more restrictions on
the right to an abortion over the years
federal courts have analyzed nearly
every kind of abortion restriction
imaginable in validating some of them
and upholding others but one thing never
changed the court's original ruling that
the right to privacy included the right
to illegal abortion but the recent case
of dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization changed all of that the
jackson women's health organization
brought this lawsuit to challenge the
constitutionality of mississippi's
gestational age act which states except
in a medical emergency or in the case of
a severe fetal abnormality a person
shall not intentionally or knowingly
perform or induce an abortion of an
unborn human being if the probable
gestational age of the unborn human
being has been determined to be greater
than 15 weeks jackson women's health was
the only remaining abortion clinic in
the state the organization won at the
federal district court level and the
district court decision was upheld by
the fifth circuit court of appeals
mississippi appealed to the supreme
court now some legal commentators
expected the supreme court to simply
overturn casey's viability analysis and
replace it with a right to an abortion
that stops at 15 weeks and in fact this
is what justice roberts advocated in his
concurring opinion however a majority of
the supreme court decided to overrule
roe and casey from the roots and allow
each state to decide whether there is a
right to an abortion or not the majority
opinion was written by justice alito and
the vote to overturn roe was five to
four justices thomas gorsuch kavanaugh
and barrett joined alito's opinion chief
justice john roberts did not join in the
opinion in overturning roe but filed a
separate concurring opinion which he
agreed with the results which is why
you'll see some people call this a six
to three decision justices kagan
sotomayor and briar dissented now
justice alito's opinion begins by
stating that abortion presents a
profound moral issue on which americans
hold sharply conflicting views the
constitution's text does not refer to
abortion alito concedes that not all
rights recognized by the court have to
be mentioned in the constitution's text
as i explained earlier the court has
held that due process guarantees of the
5th and 14th amendments protect certain
substantive rights that are not listed
in the constitution the general idea is
that certain liberties are so important
that the state cannot infringe on them
without a compelling reason no matter
how much procedural due process is given
and justice alito states that the due
process clause protects the right to
interracial marriage the right to use
contraception and the right to same-sex
marriage but it does not guarantee the
right to abortion why
well according to the majority the test
for unenumerated rights is whether the
right is deeply rooted in the nation's
history and tradition and implicit in
the concept of ordered liberty and
according to justice alito abortion
doesn't qualify under that standard and
in setting forth this test for which
unenumerated rights are permissible
alito cites washington versus glucksburg
the the case which found that there was
no constitutional right to a
physician-assisted suicide abortion is
like assisted suicide because according
to the majority
neither can trace their roots to the
founding of america the alito opinion
goes on at great length about the
history of abortion in america he states
that until the latter part of the 20th
century such a right was entirely
unknown in american law and indeed when
the 14th amendment was adopted three
quarters of the states made abortion a
crime at all stages of pregnancy and the
majority opinion says that the 50 years
between roe and the present day do not
carry any weight in establishing that
that right is deeply rooted or that
women relied on it in organizing their
lives the majority opinion concludes
that rose holding that abortion was a
liberty interest protected by due
process was incorrect the road decision
said quote the right of privacy whether
it be founded in the 14th amendment's
concept of personal liberty and
restrictions upon state action as we
feel it is or as the district court
determined in the ninth amendment's
preservation of rights to the people is
broad enough to encompass a woman's
decision whether or not to terminate her
pregnancy now alito criticized the
justices who wrote this saying that they
couldn't really put their finger on the
nature of the right and it was decided
on feelings and there's always been
controversy about that in fact many
commentators have argued the court made
a mistake in grounding the right to an
abortion in the substantive due process
clause justice ginsburg argued that the
court should have decided roe based on
the equal protection clause or the
privileges and immunities clause which
would have provided more durable
protection of the right and in dubs
several constitutional law professors
filed amicus briefs arguing that the
right to an abortion is rooted in the
equal protection clause but justice
alito said that the equal protection
clause is inapplicable because the court
had already ruled that abortion is not a
sex-based classification justice alito
rejected calls to preserve roe and casey
because of starry decisis he said that
the concept is not a straitjacket when a
ruling is grievously incorrect and
listed other landmark decisions which
upended precedent like brown versus
board of education which overruled
plessy versus ferguson's
separate but equal
doctrine and then there is starry
decisis the idea that the court should
follow precedent to foster
predictability unless it has a very good
reason not to and in assessing whether
starry decisis applied the court looked
to several factors the nature of the
court's error the quality of the
reasoning the workability of the
standard its effect on other parts of
the law and reliance interests justice
alito said started decisis was not
applicable because the original road
decision as modified by casey is quote
egregiously wrong in support of its
decision the majority opinion cites 30
other cases where the court has
overturned prior precedent as to the
five factors justice alito said that roe
was fundamentally unfair because it
foreclosed the opportunity for
anti-abortion advocates to lobby their
government for change quote those on the
losing side those who sought to advance
the state's interest in fetal life could
no longer seek to persuade their elected
representatives to adopt policies
consistent with their views
though the statement ignores the decades
of law making around abortion where
legislatures passed abortion
restrictions in response to the
democratic process and as to the
workability factor alito said that as a
practical matter the undo burden test
was too confusing to apply though he
also criticized roe's original trimester
framework as being plucked out of
nowhere and in a stunningly short
section alito wrote that overturning the
precedent would not hurt women because
there's no evidence that women rely on
the right to abortion in living their
lives he said quote conventional
concrete reliance interests are not
present here and he concluded that the
right to an abortion had nothing in
common with other types of interests
that people rely on like contract and
property rights because abortion is
unplanned and he said that if women
really think they rely on the right to
abortion they should vote he dismissed
generalized issues of reliance by saying
quote the court is ill-equipped to
assess generalized assertions about the
national psyche now obviously four other
justices robert sotomayor kagan and
breyer criticized the majority for
overruling two long-standing precedents
justice robert's concurring opinion
which we'll talk about more in a second
supported upholding roe because of
starry decisis and meanwhile the
dissenters disagreed with the majority's
conclusion that it can reverse these
abortion cases without undermining other
fundamental rights they wrote think of
someone telling you that the jenga tower
simply will not collapse however justice
alito addressed their concerns by
stating that the right to same-sex
intimate acts the right to contraception
and the right to same-sex marriage were
quantifiably different than the right to
an abortion
unlike those rights abortion terminates
a human life it affects potential life
whereas those other rights do not he
said quote nothing in this opinion
should be understood to cast doubt on
precedents that do not concern abortion
though it should be noted that this
distinction between rights that
implicate potential life is not in the
constitution and is not particularly
well supported in this context justice
alito goes on to say that since abortion
doesn't implicate any fundamental right
then mississippi's law should not be
judged according to the heightened
scrutiny that the court affords
fundamental rights instead the majority
opinion says that abortion restrictions
should be judged using the rational
basis standard of review which is the
most lenient standard of review
basically almost no law ever fails
rational basis
now it's relatively easy for state laws
to survive rational basis scrutiny the
laws are upheld as long as there is a
rational basis
which the legislature could have thought
it would serve the legitimate state
interest and elito had no problem
finding that mississippi statute met
that standard since it asserted the
state's interest in protecting the life
of the unborn and because it regulated
the medical procedure that is generally
used for abortions after the 15th week
and therefore the opinion concluded the
abortion providers challenge the law had
to fail and the elite opinion did not
analyze a woman's interest in obtaining
an abortion after 15 weeks of pregnancy
because under the rational basis review
the court outlined it wasn't necessary
to a determination of this case and that
takes us to the roberts concurrence now
the concurrences and the dissents do not
carry the force of law there was a
majority for the court and that is now
the law but
examining these uh other concurrences in
descents is interesting to let us know
where the court might be going in the
future and what the other alternatives
were with respect to the roberts
concurrence chief justice roberts agreed
with the decision to uphold the
mississippi law but he would have done
so without formally overturning roe and
casey roberts was prepared to uphold the
constitutional right to an abortion but
he would have eliminated the viability
analysis that was in place in casey he
would have characterized roe and casey
as adopting two distinct rules of
constitutional law a woman's right to
end the pregnancy and the state's power
to override a woman's right when a fetus
becomes viable justice roberts said that
the viability line quote never made any
sense the right to terminated pregnancy
should quote extend far enough to ensure
a reasonable opportunity to choose but
need not extend any further roberts
briefly surveys international law
concludes that the general proposition
is to allow abortions until around 12 to
15 weeks without regard to the viability
of the fetus roberts also points out
that mississippi did not ask the court
to eliminate the right to an abortion
the basic request was straightforward he
wrote that it was to clarify whether
abortion prohibitions before viability
are always unconstitutional for roberts
all of these factors indicated that the
best way to balance the interest was to
use judicial restraint he would have
eliminated the viability standard but
upheld the right to an abortion justice
roberts first suggested this compromise
during oral arguments but he was unable
to sway the five other justices then
there are the concurrences from justices
kavanaugh and thomas justice brett
kavanaugh said that in his view the
constitution is neutral on abortion
since the constitution is neutral then
quote this court must also be
scrupulously neutral about abortion
kavanaugh emphasized that the court
wasn't outlawing abortion nationwide and
was instead leaving the decision to the
states he wrote that the nine unelected
members of this court do not possess the
constitutional authority to override the
democratic process and to decree either
pro-life or pro-choice abortion policy
for all 330 people living in the united
states the rest of kavanaugh's opinion
was designed to reassure people that
this wasn't a radical opinion that would
upend other cases like griswold and
obergefell and he anticipates some of
the major legal issues that are probably
coming particularly whether a state can
ban its residents from traveling to
another state to obtain an abortion or
whether a state can retroactively punish
people who had abortions
he says that these are not hard
questions the answer to both of them is
no though this is just a concurrence
these answers in this concurrence have
no legal weight since these questions
were before the court and no other
justices agreed with his conclusions
that takes us to thomas's concurrence
which is sort of the opposite of
kavanaugh's concurrence justice thomas
wrote a concurrence to state that while
he agreed with the majority opinion that
there was never a due process right to
abortion the court should also make it
clear that there was no such thing as
substantive due process at all justice
thomas believes that the constitution's
due process clause only addresses the
processes the government uses before
taking a person's life liberty or
property and it has nothing to say about
the substance of the person's rights he
left no doubt about what he thought
about rights to gay marriage
contraception and same-sex intimate
conduct quote in future cases we should
reconsider all of the court's
substantive due process precedents
including griswold lawrence and
obergefell though critics noted that
thomas did not address the similar case
of loving versus virginia the case that
legalized interracial marriage and
protects the legitimacy of thomas's own
marriage it's hard to square a deeply
rooted analysis with keeping loving
versus virginia intact if the court is
going to go after the rest of the
unenumerated rights cases however loving
was also grounded in equal protection it
is related to but not totally dependent
on these substantive due process cases
he wants to overturn
that takes us to the descent of justices
breyer sotomayor and kagan
the dissenters critiqued the majorities
claim that they were simply returning
the issue to state legislatures where it
belongs quote we believe in a
constitution that puts some issues off
limits to majority rule in other words
the dissenting opinion warns that it is
dangerous for the majority to have total
control over minority rights the dissent
rejects alito's claim that rowan casey
just randomly appeared that they came
from nowhere and went nowhere this they
write is not true the dissenting opinion
takes issue with alito's statement that
casey and roe didn't allow courts to
even consider whether the state has an
interest in promoting life and the
dissent says that part of the reason the
case departed from the road trimester
analysis was because the court
recognized that after two decades the
roe framework did not give states
sufficient ability to regulate abortion
prior to viability quote the strength of
those state interests is exactly why the
court allowed greater restrictions on
the abortion right than on other rights
derived from the 14th amendment the
dissent goes on to say that what roe and
casey also recognize which state's
majority does not is that a woman's
freedom and equality are likewise
involved that fact the presence of
countervailing interest is what made the
abortion question hard and what
necessitated balancing the majority
scoffs at that idea castigating us for
repeatedly praising the balance the two
cases arrived at with the word balance
and scare quotes to the majority balance
is a dirty word as moderation is a
foreign concept the dissenters also
disagreed with alito's insistence that
the right to an abortion must be deeply
rooted in the country's history the
court quote makes this change based on a
single question did the reproductive
right recognized in roe and casey exist
in 1868 the year when the 14th amendment
was ratified the majority says and with
this much we agree that the answer to
this question is no in 1868 there was no
nationwide right to end the pregnancy
and no thought that the 14th amendment
provided one but the dissent concludes
that it doesn't make sense to ask what
was in the minds of the people who
ratified the amendment in 1868 and more
to the point quote people did not ratify
the 14th amendment men did so it is
perhaps not surprising that the
ratifiers were not perfectly attuned to
the importance of reproductive rights
for women's liberty or for their
capacity to participate as equal members
in our nation the dissent notes that
alito still thought it was necessary to
trace hostility to abortion and of
course the women's rights back to the
1300s justice alito relied heavily on
the writings of people like matthew hale
a british jurist who presided at early
american witch trials and believed women
were property of their husbands and the
dissent doesn't see why hale's writings
or any thoughts by people before the
revolutionary war should play a role in
what is acceptable today quote first it
is not clear what relevance such early
history should have even to the majority
and then the court cites the bruin gun
rights case which was decided last week
where the court held that quote
historical evidence that long predates
ratification may not illuminate the
scope of the right and the last bit is a
dig at the majority opinion in bruin
where the same justices who overruled
roe and casey concluded that when it
came to guns it didn't actually matter
if the people were allowed to carry
concealed firearms prior to ratification
of the second amendment and the dissent
accuses the majority of picking and
choosing the history that supports the
outcome they want quote if early history
obviously supported abortion rights the
majority would no doubt say that only
the views of the 14th amendment
ratifiers were germaine and many people
have accused alito of this sort of
goldilocks quasi-historical analysis
that the uh rights can't be too old and
they also can't be too new
roe has been the law for 50 years and
that does not qualify according to elito
as being deeply rooted and the leaked
draft attracted attention from
historians who said that elito got the
early history of abortion wrong many
states alito listed as banning all
abortion actually banned it only after
quickening and did not make abortion
criminal at all uh the same historical
evidence made it into the official
majority opinion
and but the dissenters took note of this
controversy saying quote embarrassingly
for the majority early law in fact does
provide some support for abortion rights
common law authorities did not treat
abortion as a crime before quickening
the point when the fetus has moved in
the womb and early american law followed
the common law rule so the criminal law
of that early time might be taken as
roughly continent with rose and casey's
different treatment of early and late
abortions and this is often a
controversy when you're talking about
originalism in some sense both the
majority and the dissent are correct
many times in american history but not
all states criminalized abortions and
many times in american history abortion
was permitted and not just in the 20th
century this just shows how difficult it
is to use historical evidence to find
the right interpretation of the text
and since early american law allowed for
legal abortion before quickening the
sense says toledo focuses on modern law
where he concludes that because most
states criminalized abortion in the
decades before roe was decided the right
wasn't deeply rooted and again the
dissent points out the majority for the
perceived hypocrisy given the bruin
decision quote
had the pre-road liberalization of
abortion laws occurred more quickly and
more widely in the 20th century the
majority would say once again that only
the ratifiers views are germane and the
dissent ends by accusing alito over
racing women and their interests from
its opinion quote the majority would
allow states to ban abortion from
conception onwards because it does not
think forced childbirth at all
implicates women's rights to equality
and freedom today's court that is does
not think there is anything of
constitutional significance attached to
a woman's control of her body and the
path of her life row and casey thought
that one-sided view misguided in some
sense that has a difference in a
nutshell between our precedence and the
majority opinion the constitutional
regime we have lived in for the last 50
years recognized competing interests and
sought to balance between them the
constitutional regime we enter today
erases the woman's interest and
recognizes only the states or the
federal governments now the dissent
tears into the majority's story decisis
analysis noting that the court may not
overrule a decision even a
constitutional one without a special
justification and as to the other
factors whether the standard is workable
whether there have been changes in the
law or fact and whether women relied on
the right to abortion the dissent takes
alito to task quote the standards row
and casey set out are perfectly workable
no changes in either law or fact have
eroded the two decisions and tens of
millions of american women have relied
and continued to rely on the right to
abortion so under traditional star
decisis principles the majority has no
special justification for the harm it
causes and according to the dissent
quote the majority comes close to
conceding that point the majority barely
mentions any legal or factual changes
that have occurred since row and casey
it suggests the two decisions are hard
for courts to implement but cannot prove
its case in the end the majority says
all it must say to override stardust
isis is one thing that it believes roe
and casey egregiously wrong that rule
could equally spell the end of any
precedent with which a bare majority of
the present court disagrees and the
dissent makes a legal realism point
incredibly bluntly quote the majority
has overruled roe and casey for one and
only one reason because it has always
despised them and now it has the votes
to discard them the majority thereby
substitutes a rule by judges for the
rule of law now i know a lot of people
are upset about this decision and we'll
talk more about what can be done in the
future but one thing you can do right
now is that there is a company that i
work with called tab for cause which
lets you raise money for charity just by
opening tabs and browsing the internet
now tab for cause responded to your
request and they just launched tab for
reproductive health which lets you raise
money for non-profit organizations
protecting and providing access to
reproductive health care like the center
for reproductive rights and planned
parenthood i know this is just a little
thing but it's something that you can do
right now the way it works is the tab
for a cause is a browser extension that
allows you to pick the charity of your
choice then every time you open up a new
tab instead of displaying a blank page
it displays a customizable tab with a
couple of tiny ads and the money that
you generate is then given to the
charity of your choice you can see in
real time how much money is being
generated and you can even customize
this tab the way that you like it and
legal eagle tabbers alone have raised
over thirty five thousand dollars for
charity i know this because tab for
causes finances are a hundred percent
transparent so you can see for yourself
how much you've raised and where it's
gone so if that sounds interesting to
you if you'd like to make a very small
difference all you have to do is click
on the link that's on screen right now
or in the description and install the
browser extension and that's it then
every page that you open will create
revenue that goes to charity so all you
have to do is click on the link that's
on screen right now or in the
description to install the browser
extension that's it and then every page
you open will create revenue that goes
to charity so all you have to do is
click on the link that's on screen
and we'll talk about more in the future
what else you can do in the wake of the
dobbs decision